we are here and it is happening welcome
to entertainment tonight coming to you
from the dolby theater in hollywood home
to this sunday's oscars the red carpet
has been rolled out the final touches
are being made and you know what
michelle this really does promise to be
an oscars like we've never seen before
it is so good to be back and you know
what part of the reason why it's going
to be great is the three hosts amy
schumer regina hall and wanda sykes
[Music]
when i was asked to co-host the oscars i
just thought what
a bad idea
who approved this this is a mistake
i was really excited and then i was
actually terrified
so how am i preparing to host the oscars
a lot of people are asking me
and
i would say it's mostly been
with drinking there's alcohol there's a
lot of that
okay so besides tipsy co-hosts what else
can we expect from the oscars trio
laughs for sure and wanda's vowing to
stick to this year's theme it's movie
lovers unite so
um
we're coming in there with with love we
want to be there we're not trying to
trash anyone but we're going to have
some fun we are going to you know
absolutely speaking of oscar fun how do
you top this viral moment from last year
icon glenn close doing the butt i think
we're gonna do that but i think we're
gonna try to get dame judith
yeah to do the worm yeah
judy we're all in as for hosting tips
amy and wanda asked two oscar veterans i
am not nervous
amy schumer dressed as ellen visited the
two-time oscar host this week the
appearance airs next month can i have
some advice i mean really like well i
think i think have fun and you know
everybody that's the thing you've been
in the business long enough that you're
gonna look out there and everybody knows
you and you know them yeah that helps
tremendously jimmy kimmel who also
hosted twice was blunt ask for a raise i
got paid fifteen thousand dollars to
host the office oh my god okay and there
was one of me you guys are probably yeah
we gotta split that
which
you know it sounds like a lot for one
night but it's months of work leading up
to it yes yeah that's a lot of work yeah
you're getting robbed as for sunday's
front runners if you're not dead
you still have a shot will smith is
expected to win his first oscar for king
richard he stars as the father of serena
and venus williams i have never been
more proud of a person in my whole life
no matter what they faced they faced it
as a family we're ready to party right
it's been a long time and all hail
jessica chastain let me give you your
beyonce advance she's up against nicole
kidman as lucy but is expected to win
best actress for the eyes of tammy fay
oh yeah
did you ever see yourself and go whoa i
was like this is a lot yeah it's a lot i
thought it was about time that we
learned her true story